In addition to the evolutionary model of motivation, we also have what's called
the drive reduction model. And, if you remember from lesson three, we talked
about the brain and homeostasis. And homeostasis is at the center of the drive
reduction model. Now, this model states that our bodies will strive to maintain
homeostasis. Psychologists have suggested that we have what's called a set
point and a set point is an ideal fixed setting of a physiological system. Such
as our temperature or even our respiration. Now our brains have the ability to
detect our physiological states and in turn our brains can activate a feedback
system that helps the body maintain physiological states. At their ideal set
point. Let's take a look at an example. Let's say you find yourself in the
Upper Peninsula of Michigan in January, without a hat, coat, or shoes. Now,
that's a very cold place to be. According to the drive reduction model, what
would happen to your body? Well, first your brain would detect those changes in
your physiological states. Most notably temperature and it would start a
cascade of events that would allow you to try to increase your temperature. For
example, you may rub your hands together. Rub your hands on your arms to warm
yourself up. Jump up and down or even eventually begin to shiver. So this
demonstrates how our body detects the change in our temperature. And it being
outside of the ideal set point, and allowed you to do things to try to raise
that temperature.